hello my name is Steve Kaufman and as
you know if you follow me here at my
youtube channel I want to talk to you
about the lang fest festival day long
that is taking place in Montreal August
25 to 27 the summer and why I think it
is a very important event and some of
the things that are going to happen
there I've been making videos now for
almost 10 years so I've been involved
with this language learning community on
the internet and I've been involved with
the evolution of language learning and
of course it's hard to be objective
because I'm a part of it but I think
what has happened is amazing in the
sense that language learning used to be
individual learners in classrooms in
schools possibly going to bookstores
buying books studying at home giving up
but basically a solitary journey very
often not a very successful one we know
the statistics at least in North America
of the rather low level of success of
people who learn languages at school
what has happened in the last ten years
is revolutionary it's the internet it's
mp3 technology and much much more so
many things have happened to enrich the
world of language learning and part of
this has that has been this outgrowth of
the the spontaneous development of a
community of people who sometimes call
themselves polyglots or enthusiasts
about language learning or even people
who want to learn their first language
and they started meeting and the size of
these meetings has grown and grown and
the cast of people who are coming to
montreal are some of the most famous
polyglots on youtube or in in language
teaching or people with different
perspectives including a four-year-old
girl from russia who speaks six or seven
languages the full spectrum old geezers
like me
little children all keen on language
learning I was at the last lang fest in
Montreal and there are people who came
from as far away as colorado and florida
and maybe from europe i don't know and
so it'll be the same thing it's a magic
atmosphere so I very much recommend that
you go i will leave a link here in the
description box so that you can find out
more about it who's coming make plants
that come and I have a question I am
thinking and I was talking to my son
Mark who is the person behind link
saying if we have so many people
gathering in Montreal maybe a day before
or a couple of days before the event we
could organize a seminar on language
learning and Link where we could provide
some in-depth perhaps explanations
demonstrations ideas about language
learning interact with people answer
their questions maybe allow people some
time to maybe explore link come back and
ask some questions so the idea is that
we would have sort of a link / language
learning seminar a day or two ahead of
the conference the conference in
Montreal I would be interested in
hearing from you as to whether this
would be of interest of any of you would
be willing to attend and so regardless
of that though I do recommend that you
visit Montreal for the long fest
festival day long but I would like to
have some feedback on this idea of
having a day or two conference amongst
people who I won't just talk about link
i'll talk about language learning but we
can interact it might be a smaller group
than will be the case of the long fist
and and we will specifically tailored
around getting the most out of link so
please let me know if you think that
would be of interest but in any case
just feel more real i hope that i will
be able to see you in Montreal
bye for now
[Music]